eine tour durch den hamburger hafen für
viele besucher der hansestadt eine der
hauptattraktionen ist der wasserstand
nicht zu hoch steuern die boote auch die
historische speicherstadt an
in dem riesigen gebäudekomplex lagerten
die hamburger kaufleute im neunzehnten
jahrhundert zollfrei ihrer importware
und veredelten sie
früher konnte man diesen ort nur mit
booten erreichen
die police total toll und die haben sie
irgendwie auch anders als in anderen
städten
vor allem kaffee tee und gewürze luden
die arbeiter einst im hafen auf kleine
boote um sie in die speicherstadt zu
bringen
zum jetzt ausgezeichneten weltkulturerbe
gehören auch bürohäuser sogenannte
kontorhäuser darunter das berühmte
chilehaus aus den 1920 er jahren
es ist eines der ersten hamburger
hochhäuser die kulturwissenschaftlerin
und welterbe expertin claudia grünberg
freut sich über die auszeichnung durch
das komitee die speicherstadt in hamburg
das chilehaus ist wirklich ein sehr
schönes neues welterbe gerade weil es
die moderne ein wenig mehr repräsentiert
wir haben hier ein tolles zusammenspiel
in der speicherstadt zwischen noch so
ein bisschen historismus aber auch schon
modernen bauten und das ist etwas was
auf der welterbe-liste insgesamt immer
noch nicht so viel repräsentiert das
finde ich es gerade schön dass wir jetzt
in deutschland ein neues welt aber haben
was eben zu den neueren gingen zählt in
den 1980 er jahren war die speicherstadt
einer der größten umschlagplätze für
orientteppiche der teppichhändler partys
an vakili nutzt die räume ganz in dieser
tradition für die lagerung und lässt sie
mit alten kränen nach draußen bringen
das dauert natürlich wesentlich länger
als wenn sie heute einfach ebenerdig
beladen mit einer ameise und dann
einfach die palette in lkw schien aber
es hat noch seinen charme
inzwischen ist die speicherstadt ein
bunter mix aus geschäften
in einem historischen speicherboden aus
dem jahr 1888 befindet sich heute ein
café
diese atmosphäre lässt so den duft der
großen weiten welt warnen
denn der kaffee der ihr angeboten mitte
stammte aus den unterschiedlichsten
ländern in den drogen fand es herrlich
das angefangen sozusagen in einer
atmosphäre eintauchen muss nach kaffee
riecht auch für deutschlands größte
modelleisenbahn ist raum in den
lagerstätten
zehn jahre lang arbeitete man an einem
konzept für ein lebendiges quartier
ich finde gerade bei der speicherstadt
wirklich das schöne an den bauten dieses
große offene funktionale wir gehen
einfach nur ein stück weit weg von dem
ganzen kitsch den ganzen
repräsentationen die man vorher so
mitgeschleppt hat und hat plötzlich sehr
sehr offene bauten die auch heute
wunderbar genutzt werden können eine
million menschen besuchen die
speicherstadt im jahr und gehen auch ins
museum
ich verstand ist der name sagt das ja
schon das ist eine stadt aus speichern
das größte zusammenhängende lagerhaus
ausnahme der welt übrigens und die
architekten haben dass hier auch früher
richtig als stadt inszeniert das sehen
sie nämlich daran dass wir statt tore
hatten
hamburg ist stolz auf seine
speicherstadt ein schon im neunzehnten
jahrhundert hochmodernes areal für
dienstleister dem damals die wohnviertel
geopfert wurden
heute ist die speicherstadt teil der
modernen hafencity mit einigen hundert
wohnungen der jetzt verliehene
unesco-welterbetitel erz ein
einzigartiges ensemble